they've waited 13 years for a home
playoff game here on the south side of
chicago and they have one with their
backs to the wall tonight the astros
lead the white sox two-nothing in the
series it is cease with the ball as he
warms up tonight for game three aj well
dylan sees tom mentioned it and he
framed it beautifully he's got to use
his off speed and the reason the astros
have hit him around is because of that
fastball he's on three career against
the astros two up two down here in the
opening inning and here comes alex
bregman defense straight up
the pitch swing gonna miss strike three
some good high gas at 100. it's the 24
year old from venezuela luis garcia who
had a fantastic official rookie year his
second career post-season start this guy
has no fear
he's a fastball cutter slider changeup
and a curveball he already faced the
white sox once this year seven innings
only seven hits one run the payoff pitch
to tim anderson
into right a base hit
lead off man is the board for the white
sox here in the bottom of the first so
two on two out here's eloy jimenez
no
one towards center field and down for a
base hit anderson rounding third the
throw from myers
white sharks take the lead in game three
right on cue it's eloy jimenez to put
the white sox in front out of the gate
here's johan monkana
towards the gap in right center field
myers hustling to the gap to make the
catch and end the inning
covering a lot of ground in that bottom
of the first back-to-back walks to start
off the inning and now it's kyle
tucker's turn the 2-0
and tucker cranks one toward right
center field headed for the gap that's
down for a base hit and that's going to
go all the way to the wall alvarez
scores correa around third and coming
home the relay by hernandez to the plate
not nearly in time it's a two-run double
for kyle tucker and the astros lead it
2-1
tucker drives in his fourth and fifth
runs of the series 2-1 astros lead
infield will come in for jake myers
on the ground past the diving moncada
it's three to one houston
jake myers coming up big in his first
post season
third hit of the series for jake myers
with mankato playing in limits the range
and that just whistled past him to his
left two out meyer's still at second for
altuve who fled out to right center in
the first
dusty ones kopeck in this game as soon
as possible because the more pitches
kopeck has to throw in this game
the less of a chance if the white sox
win and they'll see him in four or five
astros have scored three times and cease
is done michael kopeck is on for the
first time in this series
brantley lives in the air to left
jimenez is there
and kopeck comes on and gets out of the
inning but three runs across against
dylan cease so correa is on first two
outs now for tucker who had a two run
double in the second inning kopeck's
first pitch
ripped to left field pretty deep going
back jimenez still back on
two runs shot by kyle tucker the king
and the astros lead it 5-1
tucker with another opposite field homer
and he shocks the white sox
you can hear a pin drop in this stadium
right now
shift is on for grand all with one on
and one out
brondall sends it in the air to left
brantley ranging back at the wall
and it's gone
first extra base into the series for the
sox gets them back within two
and the fans are back in it
the sox needed that like they need
oxygen
this could just revive an offense that's
just been staying alive
back to back two out hits and it'll
bring up garcia liuri will bat with two
men on one oh
here comes dusty baker to make a change
they tried to stick with garcia to try
to get out of the inning but back to
back two out singles from moncada and
sheets
to oh count two outs five three houston
bottom third and tom bernucci jimmy
garcia is in
3-1 pits hammered in the air deep center
field that baby will go
a home run
re-run homer leori
and they've got the lead we talked about
the home run was needed and it has been
delivered here in the third inning
a two-run jack by grondahl a three-run
jack by leori garcia now
brantley's on first bregman one for two
had a single his last time up
back up the middle and into center field
altuve around third here comes the throw
it is cut off and alex bregman has tied
the game at six apiece a two out rally
from the astros here in the fourth
another three two swinging a miss right
three
so they do tie it
the kopeck fans alvarez the astros leave
a pair
they're at the corners with nobody out
for abreu
a brave bouncing ball past
white sox regain the lead
on his way to third robert he'll take
that base an rbi from abreu and it's 7-6
19 career post-season appearances for
zach grenky 19 starts for the first time
in his long and potentially hall of fame
career he's going to appear in the
postseason as a reliever these guys were
teammates with the dodgers and 15.
grenkey 2 grand offer
bouncing ball to the right side they're
coming home with it the throw is away
from the catcher
tom hallian got taken out by robert a
blade goes into third the ball hit the
runner grendel was inside the line to
throw home hit the runner
it hit his helmet right he was inside
the line and the ball
hit his hit hit him when gary all threw
it home
what in the world
wild wild at the plate
but he was way inside what did how what
happened to how you he got trucked by
the police robert came charging home i
think this is going to go the white sox
way and it's eight to six
and there's still nobody out and alloy
jimenez is a batter 3-2
with a roller up the line it's a fair
ball glove by the third baseman bregman
not in time one scores it's nine to six
white sox
and the ninth batter of the inning now
is cesar hernandez white sox lead nine
to six bases loaded two outs still in
the fourth of 1-1
on the ground to first guriel is there
foot race to the bag and the inning
finally comes to a close so two on now
for jimenez a couple of rbi singles and
three trips to the plate tonight
and another strikeout it's a
three strikeout frame for javier he
leaves a couple men stranded
three and two on sheets
and a good off-speed pitch from javier
for another strikeout
that's his fourth
since coming in larry garcia the batter
payoff pitch to garcia and another
strikeout five of them out of the pen
for christian javier brantley the first
astro to bad here in the seventh the one
two from bummers swing and a miss on a
slider 2-2
alvarez
two outs
called strike three on a cutter
bummer just struck out the side
as craig kimball comes on you see the
splits he's pitching the ninth inning
with the cubs on the north side in the
eighth inning on the south side with the
white sox kimbrell downhill on one two
to guriel
bouncing ball to montgomery
picked out by a grave
a one two three eighth between bummer
and kimbrell monkano reaches with two
outs
with the lefty rayleigh out there
they'll take the lefty sheets out and
bring in the right-hander andrew vaughan
in the air left center field this one is
carrying back towards the wall and it's
going to head all the way to the fence
big insurance run will score to extend
the lead to four andrew vaughn off the
bench delivers fury
right-handed with a runner at second
garcia over the third baseman bregman
another run will score vaughn comes home
one of the biggest nights of laurie
garcia's career
and they're at the corners for
tim anderson
ground ball past correa and the white
sox will add another
three in the eighth it's 12-6 it scored
five in the first two games in houston
they've put the offense together here in
game three he's ready
full count pitch swing and a miss
two down
altuve with two outs
there will be a game for
13 years since the last time
this stadium hosted a playoff game
they didn't get to see it last year
the energy the blackout
their first home playoff win since game
three against the raise in 2008.
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes